dass neukölln betrifft wirklich etwas
erzählen was sich jetzt bestürzen wird
ich habe in einem haus gelebt wo fast
nur männer lebt und abends traf man sich
in der shisha bar und ich wunderte mich
dass niemand eine maske trägt
und ich sage haben sie keine angst oder
habt ihr sie sagen ja bruder bruder
keine angst von corona da wurde mir
gesagt aller schickt immer nur ein
todfeind zur gleichen zeit und ich sage
ach so wäre es denn der andere wer ist
denn schon da der jude das kriegen sie
offen gesagt in einem neuköllner
restaurant und da sind die gleichen
leute die von der polizei mit verlaub
ungestört durch berlins straßen laufen
können und israel weg gerufen
dann sehen sie deswegen mache ich diese
ganze ganze kleister reinigt mit wir
haben eine zähne rhi die offen
gewalttätig ist die antisemitisch
auftritt er wehrt er und nicht nur da
auch die linkspartei jugendliga hat
gefordert israel weg als staat haben sie
die polizei aber
wie ist die situation erst einmal völlig
recht dass die polizei nicht in dem maße
im öffentlichen raum präsent ist wie wir
uns das wünschen das hat etwas mit
personellen möglichkeiten zu tun das hat
etwas auch mit technischen möglichkeiten
zu tun und viele andere mehr insofern
gebe ich ihnen recht da ist ein defizit
das wir seit vielen jahren beklagen auch
und gerade in berlin und nicht nur dort
und
aber dann müssen wir über das thema no
go areas nochmal in der definition
sprechen mit no go areas bezeichnen
viele menschen gebiete in die die
polizei nicht hinein geht weil sie angst
hat und ich behaupte noch einmal was
mögen sie bestreiten ich behaupte noch
mal diese gebiete gibt es in ganz
deutschland nicht es gibt wohl die
gebiete in die wir nicht mit einem
streifenwagen hinein fahren sondern
erstmal ein gruppen fahrzeug heranziehen
oder eine ganze hundertschaft weil wir
zwar im öffentlichen dienst aber nicht
bescheuert sind oder lebensmüde wenn man
sonst nicht da rein fahren kann deshalb
müssen manchmal kräfte zusammengezogen
werden und dass das versammlungsrecht in
berlin angeht und die
versammlungsfreiheit in berlin erstellt
und diese rechtlichen möglichkeiten hat
nicht die polizei gemacht deshalb sagen
sie mit die polizei duldet ist sondern
der gesetzgeber und die justiz schreiben
uns bestimmte dinge vor auch im
sammlungs recht da kann die polizei das
ist keine geschmacksfrage für die
polizei sondern sie muss sich an die
gesetzlichen vorgaben und die richter
wenig aus wenn ich das sagen darf was
ist jetzt mit diesem logo airways also
warum wurde antonia nicht geholfen warum
ist es in neukölln so dass antonia sagt
sie würde dort also dort jetzt in diesem
bereich nicht hingehen weil erstens die
polizei nicht zu jeder zeit an jedem ort
sie gleichzeitig sein kann dass der
erste punkt der zweite punkt ist weil
die polizei nicht für die einstellung
von strafverfahren zuständig ist das ist
die staatsanwaltschaft da muss man dann
auch die staatsanwaltschaft fragen darf
weil die polizei kann nur die beweise
erheben sie können beweise sichern
zeugen von dem alles mögliche machen
aber für die entscheidung im
strafverfahren ist sie schlicht wirklich
zusteht aber ich muss schon sagen das
letzte mal dass es passiert ist war
letzter mai als letztes jahr da gab es
diese riesen riesa demo also die
pro-palästinensische demo es gab es die
polizei war vor ort ich wurde
angegriffen es wurde auch gedreht also
es war sehr groß auch und also ich habe
einfach keinen polizisten gesehen danach
bin ich auch wieder nach hause gegangen
weil es war einfach zu viel für mich und
dann habe ich aber von kollegen erfahren
dass die demo total also im chaos gering
ist also die die idee die die die
palästinenser haben da die polizisten
angegriffen und umgekehrt und das dach
leider immer wieder und glauben sie mir
niemand beklagt dass mehr als ich das in
berlin jeden tag 20 polizistinnen und
polizisten angegriffen werden und
teilweise schwer verletzt werden das ist
in berlin die realität mit der ich
übrigens mich nicht abfinden werde
niemals vergessen
haben weil man nicht genügend polizisten
haben weil polizisten zu wenig dürfen
weil polizisten mit viel zu viel
nebensächlichkeiten mit klimbim
unterwegs sind und weil polizisten auch
und gerade in berlin nicht den
notwendigen politischen rückhalt haben
hier haben wir eine regierung die tag
und nacht damit beschäftigt ist der
polizei zu erklären dass in rassistische
korrupte schlägerbande ist und wir
entsprechende gesetze machen wir sind
damit beschäftigt sich die berliner
polizei das abzuwehren den mangelnden
rückhalt in der politik ist übrigens in
anderen ländern ganz anders zum beispiel
meinem heimatland nordrhein westfalen
glücklicherweise herbert reul der steht
hinter seiner polizei und der rüstet
seine polizei und vernünftig aus dass
er war jetzt auch nicht immer so das
glorreiche land ich komme auch aus nrw
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen das ist das
große leuchtende vorbild herbert reul
macht sein bestes um guten job aber ist
nrw ist das land mit den wenigsten
kleinkriminellen überhaupt nicht aber in
nrw ist das land in denen in den letzten
jahren das thema überhaupt mal auf die
tagesordnung gesetzt wurde hier in
berlin ist man der auffassung wenn
beispielsweise aus der einen arabischen
clans die leute kontrolliert werden soll
das reprofiling was natürlich hanebüchen
der blödsinn ist aber damit wird die
polizei von ihrer eigentlichen arbeit
abgehalten und in nordrhein westfalen
sagt herbert reul übrigens 15 jahren
laut innenminister wir haben zig jahre
lang dieses thema kleinkriminalität dass
sie auch als polizeigewerkschaft immer
wieder bearbeitet haben aber herbert
reul hat es doch richtig angepackt mit
personal mit technik mit besseren
polizeigesetz da läuft da kommen wir
noch einmal sehr frage eine sichere
siege braucht es in berlin mehr nrw
also ich denke das kann ich jetzt nicht
so gut ich habe wir sind ja auch in nrw
präsent als arche und ihr arbeiten in
der regel nur im brennpunkt und ich sag
jetzt etwas gewagt dass sie können mich
gerne korrigieren ich glaube dass der
ruf der polizei in der öffentlichkeit
eine lachnummer ist also die polizei sie
haben völlig recht hat keine rechte das
ist ähnlich wie die lehrer die lehrer
werden auch von den schülern ausgelacht
die polizei wird auch ausgelacht weil
letztendlich keiner mehr respekt hat und
wir haben in unserem land wenig moral
wir haben wenig respekt und da braucht
die polizei mehr unterstützung auch von
seiten der politik da muss man
deutlichere sprache sprechen und wenn
ein polizist ich bin kein polizist habe
ich beobachtet dass er selber im
brennpunkt wenn ein polizisten massiv
aussagt so hier ist wirklich stoppt ich
ziehe meine waffe dann wird er politisch
bestraft und ist das richtig weiß ich
wie gesagt ich will kein polizeistaat
aber die polizei braucht auch lassen die
polizei so wenig respektiert wenn sie
jetzt die polizei wird respektiert
werden aber die polizei und da haben sie
vollkommen recht hat keinen rückhalt die
polizei kein rückhalt da wo sie hingehen
da sind sie allein gelassen wenn sie
wirklich mal in eine gruppe gehen und
wir zeigen hier ist die grenze erreicht
dann bekommt zeichen auf dem dach und
ähnlich ist es mit dem lehrer der die
lehrer haben in unserem land auch ganz
wenig ansehen wenn sie in skandinavien
gehen da ist der beruf des lehrers hoch
anerkannt da ist der bildungsstand auch
viel besser und das eine ganz viel mit
dem anderen zu tun wie könnte man das
ändern vor allem vielleicht schon
präventiv bei den familien anfang an
kindern naja ich denke das was unser
kindern heute fehlt ist nicht nur
vernünftige bildung sondern die
rahmenbedingungen dafür dass unsere
kinder brauchen auch kontinuierliche
ansprechpartner und solange der lehrer
in einer brennpunktschule die
eierlegende wollmilchsau ist und dann
muss alles leisten hat keine
unterstützung keine psychologen an
seiner seite kein sozialpädagogen nicht
mehr menschen die auch gerade die
schwachen schüler unterstützen und die
kinder eine vertrauensperson haben dann
wird es nicht funktionieren wir sind in
einer stadt von der stadt sozusagen ball
geholt worden da hat man uns gesagt wir
haben hier in unserem in diesem bezirk
wo die arche arbeiten soll eine
straßengang schon in der zweiten
generation die verlangt wegezoll von
autofahrern die sind fühlen sich einfach
auf wie die verrückten und wir haben
dort eine art hingestellt und wir waren
eben diese kontinuierlichen
ansprechpartner für die kinder nach fünf
jahren gab es eine polizeistatistik die
hat gesagt ist wächst kein kind mehr in
diesen plan rein weil die arche dort
präsent ist mit menschen die sich um die
kinder kümmern und interessant war dass
die ältere die selbst zudem klagen
gehört haben die jüngeren ihre
geschwister die arche geschickt haben
gesagt wir wollen dass es euch besser
geht aber wir hatten keine perspektive
also alles nicht bei jedem klaren aber
alles hat auch seine geschichte und die
geschichte müssen wir hinterfragen muss
zeit haben diese geschichte zu
hinterfragen und wir müssen menschen
wieder chancen einreiben und
möglichkeiten geben und das passiert in
dieser gesellschaft sehr wenig waffen
schöne beispiele wir wollen einmal
schauen wie der status quo ist und wie
es eigentlich ja wie schlimm eigentlich
das aktuelle problem ist und an dieser
stelle mal vielen dank für ihre arbeit
übrigens wenn sie gekonnt wir schauen